the first time federal authorities are
accusing saudi arabia of a spying in the
u.s
the case involves two former twitter
employees who allegedly
gained access to thousands of accounts
jeff because reports on what's behind
all these allegations
in custody this morning ahmad abuamo
federal law enforcement sources
confirmed that he was arrested in
seattle
ali al-zabara who is a saudi citizen is
said to have fled the u.s
investigators believe the two were
working as assets of the saudi
government
and al zabara spied on upwards of 6 000
twitter accounts
some of whom were known saudi critics
the men were paid in cash and jewelry
the criminal complaint says abuamu lied
to the fbi
about his payments but received at least
three hundred thousand dollars for his
work
and tried to sell a watch a saudi
official gave him for at least twenty
thousand dollars
abuamu and al zabara are accused of
working with a saudi official
connected to the family of the country's
leader muhammad bin salman
washington post reports one of the
accounts they allegedly targeted
belonged to a dissident who later became
close to jamal khashoggi
the saudi critic and washington post
columnist who was murdered last year
u.s intelligence believes bin salman
ordered the killing
which he denies twitter cooperated with
the fbi
in this investigation which we're told
has not been reported this morning in
saudi media
in recent years there has been a debate
about the amount of user data tech
companies have and their ability to
protect it this case again
puts the spotlight on that issue and how
governments try to
exploit that information tony makes you
wonder if there are others out there
jeff thank you very much